I have the first question regarding what
you just told the board about receiving
plausible answer from Iran regarding one
of the Free State locations we heard the
response from Israel uh beginning in
Netanyahu the Israeli Prime Minister has
said they are about to political
pressure from Iran is also said that the
iaea might lose credibility of this how
do you respond to that and maybe I will
free answer and ask the second question
okay uh Also regarding the 60 enriching
of Millennium by Iran has this been now
is this now a de facto think that the
area has accepted because we don't hear
Alan bells on this you said that there's
100 kilograms of uh English to 60 why is
this not raising more concerned
but thank you very much do do very
important
questions
regarding the issue let me say that what
we have informed is that we have
received
a retire a response from Iran which is
possible and this is why
we have said that we have to offer the
questions on this particular segment of
an issue which is much wider as you know
we we continue to maintain an assessment
regarding this site where some
very specific type of testing was
conducted and we have not changed that
that assessment what we have is received
a reply that is plausible so we cannot
exclude that what they are telling us
may have happened although we do not
have any means to action
approve on this group but that what is
the case but that was the case we cannot
we cannot exclude
so then on the qualifications that
may be there or opinions or comments on
what we do that we are used to this you
know one day is one side that says one
thing and the other the other day is
another side we accept this as part of
our work our work is neutral it's
impartial it's Technical and we will
always say things as they are
the considerations of what this implies
is not up to us and I will never comment
on on governments opinions or what on
what we do what I can tell you is that
this is technical work and what we are
saying is is technically technically
correct then on the 60 well on the
reactions and why they are not more
reactions about this or then again it's
perhaps is a question that you should
approve to others not to me what we are
doing is telling International Community
the exact amount of
enriched uranium at that level of
enrichment that exists and it is as you
may have noted above 100 100 kilograms
maybe 116 or 15 something like that at
that level and the general inventory of
a rich room has been growing it's around
500 and then different amounts for the
different
of enrichment is growing as as we are
seeing and on the 60
you say have you accepted well in
reaching uranium is not forbidden as
usual what we do is verify what is
happening and we and we involve
so this would be
good
uh hi Gigi hey um just to get back to
the core of I mean we're used to hearing
you know the unhappiness from Israel
about various aspects of of this file
but there's there's a new accusation
here which is that you've essentially
watered down and Safeguard standards in
response to because of some political
considerations right so can you say the
category that's not true
um and then secondly on your statement
to the board uh where you said
um the um Iran should allow the
installation of further monitoring
equipment without further delay
suggesting there's been delay what was
that due to what has happened why is
this taking longer than you expected and
how much longer should we expect this to
go on yeah
on the standards of course we we never
ever
never ever water down our standards we
we stand by our standards we we apply
our standards and and if anything in
this
in this process which is a complex
process which you have been following
we have we have been strict
technically impartial as I like to say
very firm fair but thirdly so we don't
we're not in the business of watering
down or politically adapting anything
these are opinions we we do not take
issue with them we understand that there
may be opinions and without credit eh
well you know
um this is of course something on which
there can be opinions uh we are we have
a statement right statement that we as
you remember in March uh presupposing
that we would be implementing a number
of voluntary voluntary
additional monitoring and verification
measures and this is you know going very
slow it's the reality
we have been doing things this is why
and I think the disease is also part of
my obligation I have to report fully
what is what is pronoun it wouldn't be
fair to say that nothing is happening no
that will not be true uh the reality is
that we have installed some cameras we
haven't saw some
electronic monitoring devices some
places but there is a lot more that
leads to be done this is why since
obviously I want to have as much
capabilities
monitoring capabilities in place as soon
as possible maybe in due regard to what
your police was asking as an inventory
that is growing so I think I think we
need to be present I think we need to be
monitoring as much as we can this is why
I'm saying we need to go fast
to go fast
agency I have a question about Ukraine
um
on the sidelines of the security Council
uh meeting last week I think you
indicated that you wanted more
um IA monitors or experts in separation
and in the meantime Moscow has also
signaled that they're willing to to have
more people there so exactly how many
are there at any time now how many more
do you want
and um additional question of that is as
part of your Five Points you said that
um one of the five points is that uh
there should be no military personnel
that can carry out a tax in the plant so
how are IA experts equipped to to to
monitor that thank you very much for the
question Robert uh on the issue of uh of
the number of experts display vary uh
typically we have four people we might
have a little bit more it will depend on
the on the type of work that we need to
carry out we uh we welcome the comments
that that uh
okay
management or Russia which is in control
negative control of the of the station
would be accommodating their bigger
presence so we will we will decide
depending on the activities that we need
to carry out by clearly with
five basic principles being established
last week
we will also be assessing that against
the background of the real situation
um the whole point of doing this is
because we consider that military
activity in fact there's already report
about that
even today
the military activity in the area is
going to be increasing so there might be
a need for for working it will be that
there has been comment commentary about
the ability of our inspectors to to
monitor things we I stand by what I said
in New York you may have heard our
experts are perfectly capable of
observing and Reporting on the issues
described in this basic
principles and with regards to the to
the military presence of course we were
careful in in drafting these and in in
Consulting because these points have
been consulted with the two sides
in characterizing them as forces that
could be used to project Force as
opposed to security presence on the side
so that can give you an idea of what we
or what we have in mind thank you very
much
are there any new concerns and how is
the iea ensuring safety in the Pacific
well the concerns that exists do you
know there are countries in the region
that have expressed concerns about this
this plan and we have been carrying out
a very detailed and meticulous process
of preparing for
preparing a number of reports
and my final comprehensive report is
going to be I hope completed in a few in
a few weeks we just issued another one
so each one of our reports is public so
you may have an idea of what we have
been doing of course
the date of final decision and perhaps
start of a possible
campaign I could call discharge of this
water approaches the level of interest
on CERN and perhaps even political
discussion as we are seeing at the Royal
Governors increases and it's nothing new
specifically on the technical level we
are carrying out effective our
activities as planned
thank you hello my name is Stephanie
distenstein I'm a freelancer today
reporting for the Associated Press I'm
sorry to be asking two different
questions one on Ukraine
um in case I misunderstood you you do
not have a clear idea yet at one point
the number of monitors at znpp will be
increased is that correct my
understanding and my second question is
about the reinstalled monitoring
equipment
um the ones that you have actually
managed to reinstall uh do you have
access as of now to that data or an
agreement at what point you will have
access to that data thing thank you
about Stephanie for the two questions at
what point in general there is a my idea
is to reinforce items items will have
now A Wider
mission
a few more so there may be a need to to
reinforce the teams the the moment is
not so so relevant it may give you the
next rotation I'll do the following one
I I don't consider this as a as a point
of
substantive relevance
um segment although we reinstallment of
equipment and the access to the
information
um it's a very good point and this is
something I have raised with my Iranian
counterparts post and installment of the
equipment is very important having the
cameras that were removed or
disconnected all the electronic
monitoring devices that we may have to
control and check the the Improvement
levels and activity is very very
important but it is obvious that there
has been an important Gap in the
information and I would characterize
this as two types of cards the first in
the first place
you may remember the issues it's a bit
complex and intricate but it's like that
we had an arrangement as a result of one
of my trips from Tehran in February 32
as well when we decided that we would
have all the systems but the information
itself would be kept in a very complex
convoluted way under our seals but
without us having access to that
information that is one thing because we
never had access to that information
that information uh when when Iran
decided last summer
to disconnect the systems Etc it
remained there and then there is the gap
Gap I would say there's a gap from that
point to now where we don't have cameras
we don't we haven't had anything so no
information No cameras nothing so uh
well all we are saying and I think this
is common sense basically all right we
reconnect uh
the cameras and we have the systems
again but in order for us to be able to
reconstruct the whole picture we need to
sit down with Iran and have a some way
to uh reconstruct the jigsaw puzzle
and there may be parts that are going to
be a bit more difficult because in some
for for this first stop as I described
it we have we have the footage
so it's easier for our people
from the second part from June 2022 to
3023 then it's a matter that will
require some other type of consultation
access to records talking to people
making some projections etc etc so in
the end we can reconstruct the the
teachers say well in this period we are
our cross estimate is that such and such
amount of uh rollers and Bellows Etc has
have been have been manufactured I I
hope it's understandable if it's not I'm
sorry I can't try again
statement
that he says Iran is continuing to lie
to the iaea
that iaea is has capitulated two irons
pressure and this capitalization is a
black strange stain on the records I
just wanted whether you can specifically
address these these allegations one uh
secondly the issue of marijuana over
there
you say
um there is some explanation on some
aspects of what happened and there's and
you say standing by what you said and
your assessment stands on other issues
reasonably this this particular side I
just wondered whether you can actually
tell us exactly what according to you
happened in in in in our wedding
and that is a problem
and thirdly the issue of the 83 percent
um enrichment that was found last time a
few months back are you satisfied that
this is was an accidental thing or a
normal sort of a thing in the process or
was it more than that can you specify
that yes thank you thank you very much
all right as I said I would never enter
into a polemic or an argument with the
head of government of any member of the
IE they have their opinions and what I
said in my answer to to uh
stance I mean we never we never
resize exercises we have our standards
we apply them always
so that the in any in in any event I
would say that polynization is on the
eye of the beholder they they may be
seeing things in one way or the other
and they will criticize that we simply
do our job in the same way and we
continue doing our job uh in in the same
way and we respect companies from
everyone
on marijuana it's a long story as you
know and what I was trying to explain is
that we have a previous assessment which
is well known that in in marijuana there
have been a number of explosive
experiments in the past
for which there hasn't been any uh
reverberation for nutrient detectors to
be used with nuclear material at an
interior stage which are part of the
of the assessment the historic
assessment that the iea has been
having on this on this site then as as
you may remember the iea conducted some
access and complementary access
in 2020 or 2031
and then new traces of anthropogenic
uranium were discovered and this
particular aspect Iran has provided us
with an explanation which we
characterize as possible not impossible
so in good faith we cannot say that it
is impossible that this happened we
don't have any additional proof we have
approached other
member states which were possibly
involved in in the explanation that was
given by Iran that this was part of a
mining activities conducting at a time
at the time at the time sorry of the
Soviet Union and that perhaps as part of
this some of these traces could have
been originated because of a lab that
was located there that is not impossible
we don't have a way to prove this but we
cannot disprove it either so as we
conduct our work in good faith we cannot
still pray for the sake of keeping
something open continue to seek what is
impossible to person but as I say this
is a part a segment of a very wide
issue so these ideas that we are closing
canceling things is not accurate it's
incorrect right so I hope this is clear
and on the enrichment yes I think the
explanation was technically correct
what we of course and I think is very
credit to our excellent inspectors and
experts that were on the spot
immediately able to identify this very
high degree of enrichment
we had an analysis with the
technical operators of this facility and
again this oscillation there's an
oscillation that could be at the source
of this
very high level what we have said is
that there hasn't been any accumulation
no no uh
storage no production
at that particular level and
incidentally it is
electronic devices that we are trying to
set up are very important in giving us
an immediate impression of what happens
in case there is another oscillation or
otherwise this is we are something else
we are monitoring permanently we have to
move on the question back
yes hello ladies hello
my question goes to your last response
to my colleague yeah also in your in
your statement to the board of Governor
you will inform about the installation
of the new devices in Nathan's and for
the facilities my question is could you
tell us more about the function of the
devices and build the agency build the
iaea have access to the data of the
devices yeah yes this yes because these
are online like an online system that
allows you to read automatically or in
real time the activity Cascade or the
enrichment activity so you have direct
access to it and I think it is something
that works well because it's also in the
interest of Iran that we have a clear
view so there is no
doubt
of what is happening in any case you
would be able even in the absence of of
this I want to say in the absence of
these systems devices
we would be able as we did
when we when we found this
83.4
we would be able to do it but this
provides us with a more reliable the
immediate sort of information
thank you thank you so much for coming
thank you very much